hello and welcome to another episode of
honest trailer commentaries in this case
Zombieland oh wait no combination Oh Dan
yeah lon
dan yes and today we'll be giving our
behind-the-scenes thoughts on the
trailer you watch it together with us
then you see some cut jokes and then
we'll tease what's coming next week and
respond to comments from viewers like
you
which I'm just realizing now I forgot
but they've been emailed to me so plumby
land is a good movie there are plenty of
flaws but I don't care and I don't think
the film does either I don't know if
it's even a flaw it's just I remembered
it as being more like of its of a I
remembered it being like they're just
being more to it and when you watch it
it's like it really is like a series of
zombie themed sort of sketches yes yeah
but they're funny zombie themed sketches
so yeah it's it's still good right you
can you can kind of break it into
sections of like you know Tallahassee
and Eisenberg meet and then like the
Bill Murray section is another sketch
yeah it's a little it's like World War Z
the book which is like all these little
instances of zombie stuff right
but funny yeah I mean it's so
lackadaisical about really building like
a central narrative that the search for
Twinkies threatens to overshadow all the
other actor it's about Eisenberg
search for love no he wants to take he
wants to touch hair weird he wants to
brush someone's here yeah to not be
alone I think is like the rest of it but
he that problem is immediately solved
like in the first 10 minutes he's found
a partner alright somatic journey over
but just keep having sketches fun yeah
we did this because it was a a popular
movie and be you know sequel coming up W
made sense right to have some fun with
it
strangely popular like one of our most
requested trailers yeah people expect us
to rip everything to shreds it's like
that's not what we do say it for years
yeah that's not necessarily what we do
we're just honest
be honest take is it's good yes it's
perfectly fine yeah yeah no I I think I
mean I I feel like I get why this is
popular because it was I feel like this
was a really right time right it was the
right movie for its cultural moment it
was like at the crest of the zombie
craze and it's like a clever meta sort
of self-aware take on the genre you know
with likable sort of movie stars and
like all people who went on to have like
great future careers like I feel like
all those things kind of fell into place
yeah yeah yeah I agree and what do
Carlson and what he Harrison who doesn't
love what he girls that's terrific we
all love a good woody yeah that tumor is
worthy of a zombie later Joe yeah so
shallow is it maybe let's watch it come
together for Zombieland
in fact this movie has two characters
named after places dumber bara
conversion oh sure possible load your
zombie land names be Oh God I've lived
in like 20 places yeah Philly or some
very Philadelphia Philly Sofia Philly
yeah I'd have to be Tacoma probably yeah
I took home where Seattle yeah yeah yeah
good killing in Tacoma yeah I think it's
morphin to what city what California
city can't just be count right here LA
baby
but the the curious thing abigail
breslin and emma stone right yeah
related sisters different names and seem
like they grew up together right like
don't seem like they're they met later
in life or they're not real sisters but
they consider one another sisters like
no no sisters yeah alright okay if we
say like what is the line don't mess
with us found and this is not really
something that we have experimented much
with an auto shows Kevin our editor has
found ways now of finding great music
with words yeah like at the perfect time
it's a nice new flavor so we have these
big you buy like access to a music
library yes that you can use but it's
like overwhelming how much is in these
things yes
and there's versions of things that have
words but then you can get just the
backing track and doesn't have words
it's probably what most of that is but
Kevin has really refined this thing and
like finding a good track that'll work
instrumentally and then it has a great
tag like yeah what's that what you do
that music scene like is my question
those bands do they have their own
Grammys or their like did they have
their version the stock ease yeah there
is a guy's name is like I think like
literally Marc Ferrari yeah he's like
the godfather of like of like not of
licensable stocker I swear I think his
name is Marc Ferrari yes amazing he's
like done a lot of stuff this is very
like waiting for Guffman yeah word vs.
Ferrari
I want that Bohemian Rhapsody biopic
in my post coordinator days I had to put
together cue shoots which is the most
slavish ly taxing things to put together
cuz you have to like go through of a
video and like write down every song and
like every other off every other artist
would be my Ferrari okay I'm buying the
rights to that story alright let's keep
going civilization and everything's
going pretty good actually the roads are
clear the power still on someone put in
the code for infinite ammo and there
aren't even that many zombies now that
I'm thinking about it too this is like
the easiest apocalypse since wall-e and
one of us the drummers 20 related I
could use a 20 the last box of Twinkies
that anyone will enjoy Twinkie Twinkie
Twinkie Twinkie Lord willing at GD twink
you know what they call Twinkies in
Mexico lo submarino's it's been only
like two months man a Twinkie here is
plenty I can't Twinkie me neither didn't
they like go in a business or something
maybe they stopped production for like a
second yeah and back Americans like
freaked out and then no choice but to
figure it out there's no reaction to
Twinkies brought people out someone in
the comments and this may not be true
but comments are usually true said that
despite the reputation of Twinkies as an
apocalypse food that the shelf life of a
Twinkie is actually fairly short
particularly like the single side
imagine like hey it's gonna cream
yeah do I know where that trope started
cuz that's definitely like a repeated I
get a lot of posters about many
thousands year old Twinkie they come
Winkies worn away on the wrapper their
food lasted forever is that why you were
gone yeah I need to go back yeah I don't
know like I don't know where that joke
was bored of like Twinkies are like the
apocalypse proof food yeah but they're
there of course not no no or do
Ghostbusters have something to do is it
because they have the right but it's not
about it lasting a long time right sure
somebody knows I don't know what about
the Twinkie there you go a nice friendly
apocalypse well that's your biggest
problem let's keep going I'd rather live
in the mortal engines one zombie stuff a
social commentary blade character driven
drama or any horror at all well stick a
Twinkie up my butt and call me Woody's
this one of zom Cobb is all killer and
no filler that silly as it may be is 10
times more fun than whatever's happening
on Walking Dead these days I can't
believe that that guy's boring now yeah
that's negan just talk about your pee
panties he's having like a Kendall Roy
take it out he and Rick got into it
yeah and Rick sliced his throat but
didn't kill him what slash just you know
that classic move
yeah and then he got locked in a prison
cell forever like he literally years
locked in a prison cell and like I was
talking to people and like for a while
he was gonna escape and then he got out
and he went back to his hideout the
sanctuary was there and it was all alone
and quiet and he cried and then he went
back and put himself back in jail
and now he's like a good guy what a fun
redemption story how's the governor
doing um dinger he's still gone he's
still gone okay got that roaming the
woods no looking for his other eye ya
know maybe but not that they show ya
there's a tiger on it now let's see
there was none now he's dead promo for
this season they were doing like like
zero budget 300 reenactments for they
had like spiked shields and they were
like like really 12 of them like 12
extras well your favorite if it's any
sure until EFT on the show you do see
every three episodes oh good yeah no
it's it's it's pretty bleak it was
always bleak but some people like it
still but I'm not I still watch the show
for some reason but it's amazing they're
still doing zombie things there's
another little monsters and just saw on
Hulu yeah should be great I haven't seen
it yet some come like the worst classic
Zombo is coming out there's no making
fun of zombie I'm sorry Zambo
Zombo yeah yeah I'll give you one guess
as to what the purpose is
I'm going immediately it's a it's a
series so you'll have time that came out
last year that was a zombie musical
Christmas yeah that's so bad I liked I
enjoyed it it's fun it'll dishonor will
never happen is eventually we'll get
back to like gritty zombie horror will
be even a big once again will return
back to home base and all the reviews
would be like finally like I get back to
the pure this is what made zombies cool
in the first place we know where this is
headed where I'm actually psyched is the
Disney Plus Marvel Zombies the short one
off I mean they're doing that what if
seriously be a black there's gonna be
eat him and then travel to other
dimensions to eat other planets it's
great great comics run it is I like that
run they're alright anyways happy
Halloween keep going mm-hm
boring no yikes prepared for the film
equivalent of a michelin-starred chef
cooking a McRib in a teeny two-minute
pop Corbeau be where every actor is
oscar-worthy with Jesse Eisenberg's
first outing as an emotionally stunted
bird boy who thinks he's smarter than
everyone else
abigail breslin sunshiners soon oh yeah
I saw stove in those giant bangs every
actress was required to have a toe
yeah I don't know if mail should want me
to pull it up do it was my first comedy
headshots oh yeah baby I am a seven
right I think it's like to some time
between TV was over 2009 yeah whoo boy
did I ever have the bangs I had the
bangs for really long Zoe was patient
zero okay okay
this is Danielle sent us a picture of
what she did it was a lot it was cold
you're like like a innocent French
tourist here to teach a cold man how to
love and the important part is you have
to have the small French he or she it's
the big French here than the small
French this is definitely coming back
into style everybody so take notes yes
yeah make a note of it anyways yeah fun
fact big bang
nice after burp you guys talk
it's a big hit and Bill Murray who drops
in to remind everyone they could be
watching Ghostbusters instead Oh goodbye
Phil I didn't want to besmirched the
good name of William Armory on this
honest trailer because I know I'd get
pilloried for it but isn't it kind of an
[ __ ] move to take that role if you're
offered the role of yourself that
everybody is obsessed with they treat
you like a living God and worship you at
your feet and you're not playing an
actor you're playing yourself I know
it's a heightened version of yourself
like yeah sounds good I like that I like
the side of it did you know I didn't get
paid a whole lot to do I mean I think
it's just at this point loving Bill
Murray is such a cultural shared
cultural touchstone like you have no
choice but to it but that's like some
real self mythologizing I think it's
like it's kind of like Jeff Goldblum
taking this like Disney Plus show or
it's just Jeff Goldblum II all the time
I guess the same like you have no choice
once you become a guy like that you have
to embrace it I think it was so
over-the-top - yeah it's so opulent and
the oil paintings of himself yeah
Garfield joking right so I think there
was some self-effacement there I think
it's I liked it okay
I liked it well the other the
interesting thing I read was that they
pitched it to write him and Dustin
Hoffman weird you would have been
incredibly weird Joyce just imagining
what do you have something like Oh Rain
Man
oh I love Kramer vs Kramer Oh dresses
zombies welcome to my Shack I shoot I
Heart Huckabees yeah
trapped in the middle between lilies
yeah look that up yeah David O'Russell
and me and each other it's good outtake
one of the all-time great on set freakin
Yeah right up there with Christian Bale
and real not a Joaquin Phoenix yeah the
coming through the door thing with Lily
Tomlin is the thing that to me oh it was
too perfect if you haven't seen it it's
David O'Russell yelling at Lily Tomlin
it really makes him look awful yeah as I
said if George Clooney punches you
that's like getting like into a
fistfight with Gandhi mr. Rogers
facilitative right but he's yelling at
Lily Tomlin to calling her awful names
and they're having a disagreement and he
storms off the set that we're looking at
like out of the fourth wall and you can
hear him screaming and then he comes
back through the door Kramer entrance
keep screaming and that's I always
thought it was fake he's like that's
like comedic Lee today yeah but no
apparently very real just a monster yeah
yeah not pleasant not a pleasant working
experience yeah it would seem Wow bad
that I forgot his name at a critical
moment in my movie trivia career change
the course of history versus period well
now that was my opponent I just flat-out
forgot his name until it was too late he
thought he was like an Irish pub yeah
David don't oh yeah oh don't even go
started on that
a big controversial all right keep going
they're all combining fulfill that kind
of feels like a bunch of zombie themed
sketches or TV episodes stitched
together because that was the original
idea
so pseudo Razavi raw that's very much a
product of 2009 world of warcraft do ya
Code Red Facebook status updates but hit
B because it was meta before Deadpool
did zombies before the genre collapsed
and came out at a time free of all that
forced world building before every
universe had to expand into sequels and
spin-offs and oh well I guess it's time
that zombie genre got its Blues Brothers
2000 one of the worst movies ever made
but the standard-bearer to me of the
comedy that comes out way too late
comedy sequel that's way too you never
been a comedy sequel that came out let's
say ten years afterwards that was any
good we want it culturally we want these
things like you always hear about like
waves world 3 cuz we're trying bill &
ted's right now we're throwing the dice
on that one yes Zoolander 2 no it's like
an element of sad to it because the
passage of time like when you see the
passage of time on all the actors faces
even if they're still great and you'd
love them in another role there's just a
weight that comes along with that that I
think kind of kills the joke sometimes
yeah yeah there's nothing funny about
getting old yeah just a bittersweet 9
hilarious maybe Zombieland 2 will break
the it's impossible I'm sure could be
done yeah but why why are we getting
this I guess it's just cuz everything
gets a sequel you would think a
streaming series seems perfect and it
never seems to work out but I still feel
like that that's what this should be
like this is such a great setting and
tone and more than story like start over
new characters new actors and it's just
in Zombieland
mm-hmm yeah I don't know I guess for me
what's interesting is like now we see
these actors are like they've reached
another level of prestige yes it's like
wow they're going back to do a zombie
movie that's that's fun it could be good
yeah because at the time Woody Harrelson
was like the heavy hitter yeah there's
pre Emma Stone any Oscar nominations it
was pre Dyson burgaska nominations Abaco
president had done a little bit sunshine
but you know she was still as we
mentioned sort of at the beginning of
transitioning out of you know child
actor roles to other movies yeah yeah
it's it's crazy to think like like Emma
Stone is a Best Actress Oscar winner
yeah yeah yeah it's crazy yeah wild all
right we're you still watching remember
such a dumb friend three friends there's
gonna be carnage Bob ray man pugsy boom
stir amber alert
Tampere haunting of Bill's house Luther
V Joker coming to theaters 2022 and the
first rule of bike club is there are a
lot of rules in bike club did you really
have to write these down why these are
just common sense my guy yeah I change
the world brains were Party Time
excellent I know you have zombies but
paper money is disgusting
I think absorbs an pinkeye Danielle I
have a hold money is so gross money is
it's gross it's cool though looks cool
it has cocaine on it yeah dad that cash
has gone away cuz it's cool to have
bills and throw them and that's because
but I also enjoy making it rain but
money is kept that we know
we need that scene just for the gift
that's given us it's a great way to
communicate but also don't put money
near I'm lining about my privilege now
has a perfect visual it's not because
things are so expensive now that like
it's not really a flex to have like a
wad of bills yes congratulation
let's roll ready to delete steams let's
see what else we get you know and
starring rick rice the virgin homicide
yes no sexy Luthor dead tool redneck
Statham dead men can't jump
cowboy Curtis natural-born zombie killer
Twinkie Twinkie little star Harrelson
[Music]
dead when walking Little Rock Arkansas
Little Rock passed her neck I'm just
very disappointed that the Billy Joel
reference didn't yeah why didn't I
usually just see whatever's winning the
vote in the notes and that that didn't
take it
so I endorsed it it was great I also
pitched it so I guess that's no surprise
I think I also endorse this one I don't
know well that's the unofficial it could
have been our first we didn't start the
fire we do that whole lot of it didn't
you yeah yeah nailed it though you know
that sounds great yeah thank you coming
Little Rock Pasternak mickey mantle
kerouac sputnik Joe in life Bridge on
the River Kwai Rock sunshine hey amber
heard you were a zombie and alive
traumatic misdeeds is ooh if anyone asks
you if you're a zombie
you say no candide cameo and Joaquin is
that you barks and desiccation
the Kentucky died movie history of the
zombie world partner you like them yeah
yeah friends the one with the zombie
apocalypse the quick and the dead
so what's the one special I think that's
a pun right there all right so you guys
chat briefly while I bring up the email
with your comments on it yeah nailed it
and six thousands right rights seriously
do we need a sequel I mean I think we
addressed that we don't we heard the
same thing about El Camino all this way
do we need things we didn't need a
godfather to yeah there's great we don't
need entertainment yes close your eyes
and cursor renard right did they make a
zombie LED TV series with different
actors on Amazon but it failed it did
yes one of those pilots that didn't get
more Amazon was like that's not good
another biggest mistake was it was the
same characters with different actors
and that yeah yeah what a huge missed
opportunity
I'm cannae to see the same characters
with different actors yeah it couldn't
be for different people
yeah yeah alright hey commentaries
please talk about how this movie is just
Max Brooks is Zombie Survival Guide I
had that that's like rules and that sort
of tone of it there's similarities yeah
that's all zombie movies are more or
less derivative of each other yeah it's
very you know there's some like the
motion is pretty much the only thing you
can monkey with it right is are they
fast or slow or somewhere in between
yeah and then everything else is more or
less okay there's a few where they can
toss
raise or lower the social commentary
this one I think had close to my
favorite roger ebert quote who we got
from someone else which is it's not what
it's about it's how it's about it so
it's yeah it's how how different things
are it's an amusement park what's up
it's a zombie land if you will who is
okay this did make it in the trailer
know who was operating those rides more
it's a hot also a haunted assumption
maybe is that the rides are on some sort
of a cycle so you could hit start jump
on and it'll say there's like 12
different teenagers with braces putting
your life in their hands I think they're
better off with the zombies and carnies
go picture and then finally are always
our favorite all the people piling on to
say you copied since the same release
scheduled not the same release schedule
but we look at what's coming out and I
think we all react accordingly there's
no there's a sequel coming this weekend
yeah so a lot of people are going to
have the same idea of revisiting the
first because a lot of people are
searching for zombie land and we would
like them to land on us when they do
that yeah that's how they land on our
page come on go to the polls the idea
that in two hours we could like write
and produce an honest chariot not now
the internet works people but that no
shouldn't stop you from commenting what
should stop you from commenting is my
crappy clue for next week next week's on
its trailer is something that you may or
may not remember yeah we'll see yeah no
but next week you'll have to find out
yeah we'll see you then thanks for
watching
we already did momento
[Laughter]
[Music]
you